[Music]
hey guys it's Joanna here today we're
going to be talking about my favorite
super fruits goji berries goji berries
are nature's most nutrient dense fruit
the super berry is native to the
Himalayan mountains of Tibet and
Mongolia because of its popularity goji
berries are now growing in many other
countries as well if you have never
tried a goji berries before they have a
mult ng taste that is slightly sweet and
sour when joined they have a similar
shape and chewy texture as raisins I've
got a consuming goji berries in my home
made soups I never really knew what they
were all the benefits all I knew was
that they made the soup taste sweeter
and it's good for your health
because Chinese medicine practitioners
have been using them for thousands of
years but of course nowadays goji
berries are marketed as one of the top
superfoods it contains all essential
amino acids and has the highest
concentration of protein amongst other
fruits health and ideal choice to meet
your daily protein requirements it has
the highest vitamin C of any fruit
content in the world the fresh berries
have 400 times more vitamin C than
oranges and the dried berries have about
seven times more than oranges it has 21
trace minerals high in fiber and has 15
times more iron found in spinach as well
as calcium zinc and more these are just
some nutritional values so let's explore
the benefits and why you should add this
superfood into your daily diet first
anti-aging goji berries is known as the
world's most powerful anti-aging food
thanks to its antioxidant properties
which delays the aging of cells in Tibet
Beauty berries are known as
the key to eternal youth according to a
legend the Chinese herbalist Li Ching
Yin was documented by the government of
China as having lived to 252 years of
age he was born in 1678 and lived to
1913 one of his secrets was eating dirty
berries on a daily basis I mean I am not
too sure how accurate this legend is the
second benefit to correct Chi
deficiencies in traditional Chinese
medicine goji berry is dead
- correct Qi deficiencies such as low
energy fatigue insomnia and anxiety Chi
is the body's vital life force energy it
can be damaged by overworking over
exercising overthinking or stress on
healthy eating aging illnesses and more
goji berries are used to rebalance Chi
by boosting energy levels reduce stress
and balances the immune system the next
benefit weight loss or weight
maintenance now remember it's ignorant
to berries solely without changing your
lifestyle will not help you to lose
weight it is still a combination of
eating a well-balanced diet with regular
exercises there will help you with your
weight loss say that however goji
berries do contain many health
properties that will aid in your weight
loss process for instance it going to
berries are low in calories and
completely fat-free 1 tablespoon of goji
berries has only 18 calories and 1 gram
of protein it is also low in Kosilek
index levels scoring at 29 it is lower
than apples and majority of other fruits
it is also high in fiber which means
feeling fuller for longer and keeping
your blood sugar levels stable thanks to
its high protein content these berries
also promote muscle growth one study has
shown that goji berries can improve
exercise endurance boost metabolism
improve workout performance overall so
adding a
a lot of goji berries into your daily
diet may help to enhance your weight
loss goal or to maintain a healthy
weight
The Fault benefits and the information
and glowy skin this amazing little
superfood also contains natural
anti-inflammation properties it has been
known to help with reduce skin
inflammation skin rashes scars acne and
protect against skin damage Beauty
berries are also rich in vitamin E which
gives you a soft glowing skin and
continued fatty acid which can stimulate
collagen production resulting in younger
looking skin so ladies it is never too
young or too old to eat goji berries
next benefit sharper vision ZN thin and
lutein are two components that keep our
eyes healthy and goji berries contain
both ingredients consuming a small
amount of goji berries every day will
not only make your vision shovel but to
also protect your retina against any eye
conditions this is especially important
with our modern daily habits of staring
and working long hours in front of the
computers
this can cause soreness and tightness to
the eyes and so any consumption of goji
berries can help reduce these symptoms
so if you are one of those that stares
at the computers for long hours do not
forget your daily dose of goji berries
and of course allow your eyes to rest
too I personally find this has helped me
out regular consumption of goji berries
are also known to keep our vital organs
healthy and it is very commonly used by
Chinese medicine practitioners goji
berries help to control cholesterol and
blood pressure which keeps the heart
healthy it is also used in Asia to treat
diabetes and to help regulate high blood
sugar it also protects the liver and
kidney and helps in all types of
digestive problems such as ulcer and
irritable bowel syndrome goji extracts
may
prevent the growth of cancer cells and
the final benefit healthier sex life in
Asia Beauty fairies are traditionally
known as a strong sexual tonic as we age
Aloha sex drive can be linked with the
decreased production of testosterone
consuming goji berries can help to
increase its production to increase
overall stamina well-being hence a
healthier sex life so the question is
how much should you eat in a day since
goji berries are so neutral dance a good
starting point would be to consume
between two to three tablespoons to gain
the health benefits there are many ways
you can consume goji berries first to
eat them raw as snacks it just like
raisins
chances are if you are not used to it
you might not like the taste and it
might be better for you to add them in
your drinks or food you can blend them
in smoothies it will make your smoothie
taste sweeter and that in trail mix
muesli serials of oatmeal you can even
add them in her booties allow them to
soak for 5 to 10 minutes and they will
be plump and juicy and you will have
your GT you can even use them as baking
ingredients and add them in muffins
stones or energy bar just think of them
as what you would use with raisins or
add them in your stew just like how I
have been brought up eating them so
where can you buy Geary berries goji
berries are mostly sold as dried fruits
if you live in Asia
chances are goji berries are already
part of your daily diet and it is
extremely easy to buy from any grocer or
Chinese medicine stores at a really low
price in the Western countries however
goji berries are marketed as a health
food and you want to be careful not to
pay extremely high prices with the
marketing place although it is the
world's most nutrient dense superfood
you can get it at a much lower price do
not only start from health stores you
and go to an oriental supermarket and
even find them in major supermarkets at
much lower price for instance I bought
this packet and only one pound 18 and of
course trying to sauce for organic eager
G berries so with all the health
benefits are there any side effects goji
berries have very few side effects and
have been consumed regularly by Asians
however if you have food allergies
you're pregnant or you're a nursing
mother please consult your doctor before
changing your diet goji berries can also
interact with blood thinner and other
medications so if you are on medications
again please consult your doctor before
consuming them like anything else
remember to consume goji berries in
moderation and you can't go wrong try
this superfood out and let me know what
is your favorite way to consume goji
berries I like them in my smoothie and
soup so let me know in the comments
below for new Fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you
[Music]